hey schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute
live am donnerstag gehört die stadt der
eintracht das teilte die frankfurter
stadtverwaltung mit und hat alle gebeten
die heute nicht mit der eintracht feiern
möchten die innenstadt zu meiden denn
dort herrscht gerade ausnahmezustand
alle warten auf die mannschaft auf dem
römerberg in der innenstadt in diesen
minuten die jetzt gerade dort nach einem
sehr langen autokorso ankommt und heute
wir schon kurz darauf um 18 uhr und um
18 uhr sind sie erstmal gelandet am
frankfurter flughafen
und dann ging es nämlich los mit einem
langen autokorso hier sieht man erst mal
den flieger und die mannschaft die dann
auch ausgestiegen ist ich meine es war
zuerst der trainer der trainer und der
kapitän aber das werden wir gleich sehen
und wenn die flugzeugtüren aufgeht das
war also um 18 uhr und dann gab es
erstmal einen sehr sehr langen autokorso
den wir jetzt die ganze zeit verfolgt
haben durch die innenstadt warum hat es
so lange gedauert weil alles voller fans
war natürlich die mit ihrer mannschaft
feiern wollen die stadt ist voll die
straßen dicht also dass im moment
wirklich kein durchkommen mehr und hier
sehen wir den pokal denn was ist
passiert wer es noch nicht mitbekommen
hat der eintracht der frankfurter
eintracht ist das gestern gelungen was
sie schon 42 jahre lang nicht mehr
geschafft hatte frankfurt gewinnt gegen
die glasgow rangers den europacup und
das ist historisch für diese mannschaft
für die fans die euphorisch jetzt schon
den ganzen tag und auch die letzten acht
schon in der stadt unterwegs sind und
deshalb feiert die stadt heute ihre
helden und wir nehmen euch mit jetzt
live in diesem moment und auch gleich
eben wenn die mannschaft dann zu sehen
ist auf dem römerberg in der innenstadt
und ihr könnt kommentieren live im
stream fragen stellen per mail oder
einfach mit uns dabei sein und zu
schauen und dieses diese fan freude
diese jubel bilder anschauen und wir
schalten jetzt auch direkt mal live auf
den römerberg zu markus wolsiffer meine
ich müssen wir zuerst sprechender steht
für uns nämlich live vor ort und
ich höre aber gerade das ist so sander
santina zuerst meine kollegin werden
zwei kollegen vor ort da ist viel los
und wir können jetzt mit ihr sprechen
mit susanna seiten tina live in
frankfurt verbindung ein bisschen
geschwächt aber ich hoffe der ton ist
gut susanne wie ist gerade die stimmung
wie viele menschen sind da um sich
die stimmung ist schon seit heute morgen
einfach grandios jetzt mittlerweile sind
hier auf dem römerberg rund 12.000 leute
die anderen vielen fernsehen der mit
rund 200.000 gerechnet haben sich auf
die anderen plätze hier in frankfurt
verteilt also es sind einfach so viele
da die ihre mannschaft feiern wollten
nach diesem historischen sieg ist und
ich habe hier auch paar fans frei wie zb
thomas
noch was mag ja ich wollte sagen du
stehst da nicht alleine sondern wer ist
bei dir erzähl uns genau ja
also wir haben ja ganz viele
eingefleischte
frankfurt 1 zb
wie hast du den gestrigen tag erlebt
total unbeschreibliche lange bei der
eintracht
wir wollten natürlich live hinfahren
bemüht um die karten hat nicht geklappt
beim public viewing auch in das projekt
letztendlich haben eine eingefleischte
eintrag kanal will das spiel geschaut
sensationell
unbeschreiblich was die mannschaft
geleistet hat
formell peter war mir klar dass wir es
holen nach 0 1 habe ich gedacht jetzt 1
1 im elfmeterschießen und das glück muss
sie auch jetzt auf unserer seite sein
und daher absolut optimistisch
unbeschreiblich
mir geht's super gut wir sind heute
schon so lange da und ich muss nochmal
ein dank ausrichten an meine
allerliebste großtante dass sie mich zur
antrag gebracht hat waren sind dass das
hier ausleben durfte und das absolute
hoch hängt heute
so und wir machen zusammen zu markus
heitz 30 erfolg ist die eintracht und 96
habe ich live den abstieg miterlebt und
das ist mir jetzt noch mal den
europapokal holen
[Applaus]
dollar
natürlich ist auf der hund mit nach dem
oberberg die mannschaft jetzt gerade
schön anzusehen oder was man kann moment
nein wir warten noch auf die mannschaft
ganz gebannt hier gibt es eine große
videoleinwand und da wurde regelmäßig
gejubelt vorhin wurde auch das
elfmeterschießen noch einmal gezeigt
aber natürlich hat man viel geduld heute
gebraucht so sonne hat es gesagt hat den
frühen morgen stehen einige hier jetzt
hat es zwischenzeitlich geregnet aber
niemand ist nach hause gegangen wir
haben sie noch nicht gesehen aber sie
nähern sich und es wird jeden moment
soweit sein ursprünglich sollte sich die
mannschaft zuerst in das goldene buch
der stadt eintragen jetzt heißt es nein
zuerst muss es auf den balkon gehen man
will gemeinsam mit den fans feiern und
den pokal in die höhe strecken
wir hoffen uns rüber schwenken in dem
moment wäre die mannschaft kommt jetzt
gerade hier
letzte nacht unterwegs wo sie das spiel
um starke angeschlossen den ganzen tag
unterwegs ist die stimmung und ist die
stimmung heute noch ausgelacht haben
gelassen und ich nahm aber die kämpferin
die mannschaft hat schmecken darüber
dass wir auf jeden fall diesen moment
nicht verpasst auf die leinwand
wir können kurz auf die videoleinwand
schränken trainer ich hab' ich bitte war
den kollegen kurz mal zur seite zu gehen
ganz kurz mittel zur seite dessen kurzes
bild bekommen
so die mannschaft zieht also in diesen
sekunden ein louis blues zu hören
wie barack obama zu hören ganz genau und
die mannschaft zwei wochen nämlich weiß
an wir wollen ein buch ein richtig
markus kannst du nicht wieder gar
markus kannst du mich hören
wir versuchen hier gleich nochmal zu
markus wolle sich darüber zu schalten
der uns ja gerade auch dabei war zu
erzählen was jetzt passiert mit der
mannschaft in diesen minuten die meines
wissens nach sich jetzt zuerst zuerst in
das goldene buch einträgt und wir
bleiben jetzt vielleicht auch mal ein
moment auf diesem bild das ist der
balkon auf dem nämlich alle jetzt
starten schon den ganzen tag und hoffen
und warten dass da also gleich ihre
mannschaft zu sehen ist markus hat es
uns ja berichtet es sind wirklich viele
schon seit neun uhr morgens unterwegs
haben kaum geschlafen haben die ganze
nacht gefeiert und jetzt stehe neben
super viele menschen in der innenstadt
an mehreren plätzen nicht nur da jetzt
auf dem römerberg was wir also gerade im
livebild zeigen können sondern in der
ganzen stadt wäre es vielleicht auch
schon ein bisschen verfolgt hat den tag
über der der oder die hat wirklich also
volle straßen gesehen und auch eine
mannschaft die wahnsinnig viel zeit sich
nimmt für ihre fans die ständig stehen
geblieben in den autos mit dem korso
deswegen hat auch so lange gedauert die
man eigentlich vor 200 stunden schon
eingeplant um zusammen mit den fans in
der innenstadt zu feiern aber einfach
die sind stehen geblieben sie haben sich
zeit genommen für ihre fans für service
für kurze gespräche für handschlag also
da hat man mehrere freudige szenen
gesehen und jetzt aber natürlich wartet
die ganze stadt auf diesem moment es hat
einfach sehr sehr lange gedauert und es
ist vor allem natürlich auch eine
mannschaft die gestern hat wir können es
auch später noch mal in einem beitrag
sehen aber jetzt beim essen auf dem bild
eine
mannschaft die gestern ihre fans hat bis
zur letzten minute zittern lassen das
war ein elfmeterschießen das also alles
entschieden hat deswegen das adrenalin
und die aufregung war groß entschuldigt
bitte dieses etwas gruselige bröselige
livebild aber da sind natürlich jetzt
gerade viele menschen in der innenstadt
was zumindest unsere technik hier ein
wenig leiden lässt aber ich hoffe dass
wir trotz dieser 14 partei jetzt wird es
wieder ein bisschen schlechter aber
natürlich im entscheidenden moment wenn
die mannschaft denn da ist ein gutes
bild bekommen und danach können wir dann
auch natürlich hoffen nicht noch mal mit
unseren reportern sprechen ich schaue
gerade mal in den stream ob es von eurer
seite da vielleicht auch schon erste
fragen und kommentaren gibt es netz
sehen wir es natürlich auch im
vordergrund immer wieder menschen die
grillen und feiern das gehört auch dazu
natürlich zu dieser freude ist ja aber
jetzt wenn der kollege nicht zur seite
geht sehr gut das macht da können wir
natürlich auch nicht sonst die
mannschaft sehen jetzt ist natürlich die
frage wie lange wird das dauern sich in
dieses goldene buch einzutragen das
können wir nicht so gut abschätzen so
wie wir den ganzen tag schon
probleme hatten natürlich das
einzuschätzen ich glaube keiner hat das
kommen oder na ja viele haben es nicht
kommen sehen dass es so lange gedauert
aber ist ja auch gar nicht schlimm es
ist tatsächlich ja noch eine herrliche
sommernacht nach dem kurzen regen den
alle dort ausgehalten haben das wird
sich zwischendrin sind hat man einige
nasse gesichter gesehen
warten jetzt aber natürlich alle auf
diesen entscheidenden moment und wollen
ihn auch nicht verpassen deswegen ich
würd mal vorschlagen die gehens vollbild
wir schauen mal zusammen drauf und ich
gehe derweil auf durch eure kommentare
versucht ein bisschen was zu sammeln
dass wir dann später noch mit unseren
reporterinnen und reporter darüber
sprechen können
[Musik]
so und da das noch ein weilchen dauert
würde ich vorschlagen den schalter noch
mal zu machen weil du hast nämlich
gerade dabei uns zu empfehlen auf die
stimmung heute sogar noch rausfinden
erst dann wenn du hast ja einsetzen
[Musik]
ja wir waren gestern nach dem stadion
hatten auch das gefühl
begeisterungsfähigkeit lässt sich nicht
mehr steigern die fans der frankfurter
eintracht zu weisen regelmäßig das
gegenteil das war gestern ein
ohrenbetäubender lärm wir haben uns
etwas in die ohren gesteckt damit wir es
überhaupt aushalten konnten heute morgen
ging es dann direkt weiter viele haben
gar nicht geschlafen haben mit einer
dame gesprochen hatte nachtschicht und
ging anschließend direkt hier zum römer
und meinen guten platziert zu haben
anfangs war der vordere bereich noch
frei weil der platz freigehalten wurde
für die ultras sind ja die ganz
engagierten fans und die haben natürlich
auch den wunsch ganz nah dabei zu sein
was die fans auf die beine stellen mit
diesen riesigen fanaufkommen in
barcelona zum beispiel das sind
erinnerungen die für viele ein leben
lang bleiben dass man 30.000 fans im
kampf im hof anschließend gab es den
sieg in west ham und natürlich den sieg
hier gegen west ham alles wunderbare
erinnerungen jetzt seit 42 jahren die
haben es gehört endlich wieder einen
titel auf europäischer bühne seit 18 war
der dfb-pokal sie das wurde schon riesig
gefeiert aber das ist noch eine stufe
mehr
markus und jetzt warten wir natürlich
auf die mannschaft der messe portalhaus
kommt und dazu gibt's nur starke von
fernande bei youtube der befragten ist
der fall
hey
[Musik]
das würden wir auch gerne das kann ich
leider nicht verurteilen das ist
natürlich immer eine frage sieht man
beim autokorso den echten pokal ab und
zweifel stellt er runter dann muss er
ersetzt werden das gar nicht aktuell
nichts sagen haben gestern einige fans
gesehen die natürlich in eigenen pokal
gebastelt haben diese gibt es immer
wieder die haben sie uns gezeigt und
waren ganz stolz drauf und heute ist es
soweit gleich
gibt es ihn auf den balkon irgendwie
wird's noch mal lauter weil noch mal
reden gehalten werden im saal gleich
geschlossen
wir leben gehalten hier frankfurt und
wir schauen jetzt aber mal zusammen
zurück und schauen mal auf dem weg der
eintracht im bis 7 die kämpfe waren und
sich auch spannend ist zur letzten
minute ein beitrag von gestern
die historische europa league reise der
eintracht startet im september
gruppe d gegen olympiakos piräus
fenerbahce istanbul und antwerpen die
hessen machen es immer wieder spannend
in piräus fällt der siegtreffer in der
91 minute auch gegen antwerpen zwei
entscheidende tore in der nachspielzeit
eines im hin und eines im rückspiel
frankfurt wird gruppensieger steht er im
achtelfinale gegen betis sevilla im
rückspiel wird es dramatisch
verlängerung und wieder last-minute-tor
frankfurt dann dieses los im
viertelfinale der große fc barcelona das
rückspiel im camp nou ein abend für die
geschichtsbücher vor 30.000 mitgereisten
fans gewinnen die adler 3 zu 2 im
halbfinale geht es gegen west ham nach
49 sekunden köpfte ansgar knauf die
hessen im hinspiel in führung danach
lässt frankfurt nichts mehr anbrennen
und dann die krönung finale in sevilla
sieg im elfmeterschießen gegen die
glasgow rangers für die eintracht ist es
der erste internationale titel seit 42
jahren
kein spiel für schwache nerven gestern
rückstand 120 minuten kampf dann
elfmeter und jetzt eben der große sieg
zu seiner santina ist mir wieder
zugeschaltet sie steht auch für uns eben
live auf dem römerberg und vor allem
zusammen mit einem ganz super fan mit
thomas und susanne wie was hat thomas
diehr berichtet er ist ja auch noch bei
dir war er jetzt selbst auch in zivil
ist er zuvor schon häufig mitgereist die
frankfurter fans die reisen ja oft und
in großer zahl ins ausland
in unsere legendären kneipe im
bischofsheimer bahnhof genial eintrat
kneipe total auto gemacht alle
mitgefiebert gigantisch
war gestern im waldstadion habe leider
keine tickets für sie will er bekommen
und im waldstadion was einfach
sensationell und die eintracht hat das
so dramatisch wieder zu ende gespielt
märz am anfang auch die gewinne in der
ersten halbzeit 3 0 typisch eintracht
nachher alles spannend gemacht und wir
haben wir das ding geholt sensationell
ja natürlich das auf die spitze
getrieben aber im endeffekt scheiß egal
wir haben das ding sei
ich denke sehr großen also wir haben die
ganze zeit freunde gepeitschten ich
denke dass es auch der hauptgrund wieso
die interaktion traditionsvereines
dieser fans hat was andere mannschaften
nicht haben ich denke dass ich die
besten fans in ganz europa so ist es die
mannschaft so nach vorne dass sie auch
so spiele gewinnen kann und
zu seiner fragte heute noch nach ich hör
dich so seiner fragt doch bitte noch
einmal nach ob die drei damit gerechnet
haben bei 2016 hat die mannschaft noch
um den abstieg gerungen und musste da
kämpfen und jetzt also dieser krasse
sieg haben die damit gerechnet
[Musik]
jetzt gleich ich bin ja sehr gerne fragt
gerne natürlich gewahrt
[Musik]
zusammen
ganz ehrlich ja weil wir fenstern
geglaubt haben gewohnheit anfang
2011 waren wir noch randale meister und
europacupsieger
überhaupt ist
wir hatten ja noch ein ziel wir wollen
international spielen das machst du ganz
einfach wenn der roboter kalte gebissen
man muss sich fokussieren so ist es im
leben
ja total im sind einfach es sind wie ich
sagte die besten tänzer in ganz europa
und die mannschaft glaubt daran die
mannschaft pusht das und guckt der
andere vereine an alleine wie viel in
barcelona waren wo wir auch wahren damit
auch nach vorne gepusht reiche bringt
auch das spricht weiß ich heute davon
und wie war der spannende spiele waren
hat frankfurt sehr sehr gut gespielt
ja lisa ja danke euch für diese
eindrücke ist natürlich laut bisher klar
ich ließ die türen gehen jetzt wohl auf
dem balkon deswegen würde ich fast sagen
ihr seid so nett geschenk noch mal
drüber damit wir vielleicht jetzt dann
doch die mannschaft endlich sehen können
ja das machen wir jetzt super tanker hat
sich jetzt auf den balkon was christus
oder ist es einfach nur jubel wie zuvor
die
gemeinsam schauen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir haben
zeit wissen mit dem
damit konnte
für seine nächste seite
nehmen wir natürlich auch sitz wir nicht
sehen
ja das trifft für dunkel aber am ende
ein loch möglich und zur mannschaft
passen ich würde sagen mit dem bruder
falls die fans nehmen ihnen auch
anspricht sind wäre natürlich die frage
susanna und andere von den riesigen
moment jetzt gerade erleben ist steht
die schalter noch zu seiner santina dann
wäre es prima wenn wir da noch mal kurz
rüber schauen weil jetzt gerade sehen
wir hier auf diesem bild ist ein
standbild oder nicht es ist nicht ganz
klar zu erkennen aber na ja gut ich
guckt er weil man eure kommentare wenn
ich hier kurz den moment habe und auch
susanne erwarte diese kommt beschreibt
bei youtube youtube ich interessiere
mich nicht für fußball aber es ist schön
wenn sich mein menschen einfach mal
wieder freuen können das ist natürlich
richtig dass das jetzt das erste größere
event dieser art ist auch nach der
langen corona zeit und dass da jetzt so
viele menschen gemeinsam feiern ich
würde noch ein letztes mal versuchen zu
meiner kollegin susanne santina zu
schalten aber möglicherweise jetzt
gerade in diesem moment den alle
festhalten und raus posten streamen
wollen zu ihren liebsten ist natürlich
mit dem empfang auch nicht mehr so viel
los gehört ich höre es auch wenn er zwei
mal wieder gesänge aber wir können jetzt
den kontakt zu seiner sein team nicht
mehr herstellen aber wir hoffen wir
konnten euch zumindest ein kurzes
stimmungsbild geben was da gerade los
sein muss in frankfurt auf dem römerberg
ich glaube jetzt wird nur noch gefeiert
die stimmung da und die freude
grenzenlos im august wird frankfurt den
supercup spielen gegner könnte dort real
madrid oder der fc liverpool sein und
dann können wir uns jetzt nach heute
glaube ich schon vorstellen was dann
nach vielleicht auch noch mal los sein
wird danke dass ihr heute kurz dabei
wart wir hoffen wir konnten uns wir
konnten euch da eben ein bisschen
mitnehmen und bis zum nächsten mal
tschüss